[Musique]
nous recevons aujourd'hui une figure
emblématique de la vie politique
française
ancienne candidate à la présidentielle
ancien ministre des sports et député
communiste de seine saint denis depuis
20 ans bonjour marie george buffet au jo
alors on est réuni pour faire un peu le
bilan de vos années à l'assemblée avant
de tourner cette page dans quel état
d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
et je suis élu je mon premier mandat
c'était en 1977 jeter maire adjointe à
l'action sociale et je vais avoir 60 13
ans et j'ai envie de passer quelques
années où je pourrais choisir mon emploi
du temps je pourrai je serai toujours
bien sûr engagé mais j'ai envie d'une
certaine liberté voilà on va parler ça
dans la dernière partie de notre
émission n'ont pas commencé un peu par
le bilan politique de marie george
buffet c'est parti pour cette dernière
séance
alors dans les films les personnages
principaux font parfois d entrée
discrète ça a été votre cas à
l'assemblée puisque vous avez été élus
aux législatives de 1997 on a d'ailleurs
retrouvé les images de vos premiers pas
à cette occasion ce que vous aviez
visité en tant que député à l'assemblée
avec robert hue sauf que vous n'avez pas
siéger parce que vous avez été nommé
ministre des sports dans le gouvernement
de lionel jospin vous souvenez de ce
moment là oui je me souviens tout à fait
voilà j'étais vraiment décidé à
mener mon mandat de député ça a été pour
moi une très grande surprise j'avais
d'ailleurs quitté le siège du parti
communiste le soir des élections je
rentrais chez moi et à ce moment là
c'était les premiers portables gros
portable a sonné dans la voiture et
c'était robert hue qui m'appelait remet
qu'ils info que tu reviennes tu
reviennes place fabien parce que le
premier ministre va t'appeler et donc
j'ai pas pu siéger puis voilà et on vous
voilà dans le numéro deux de lionel
jospin et c'est donc en tant que
ministre que vous avez un peu connue
votre baptême du feu à l'assemblée en
défendant votre loi de lutte contre le
dopage on va voir que durcir la lutte
contre le dopage à l'époque ça n'allait
pas de soi trop vite trop tôt j'ai
entendu plusieurs fois cela mais trop
vite trop tôt par rapport à quoi
trop vite trop tôt mais on va attendre
quoi on va attendre que d'autres jeunes
un peu en aval ce mélange de cocaïne
d'héroïne d'amphétamines ces terrains on
attend de ce projet de loi soit adopté
dans de nombreux pays pour pouvoir
l'étudier travailler et modifier des
législations c'est ce que m'ont dit les
ministres en rien alors pour se remettre
dans le contexte d'un vote loi elle est
arrivée juste après ce qu'on appelait l
affaire festina qui avait marqué le tour
de france en 98 certains vous ont
vraiment reprocher d'aller trop vite
trop tôt dans la lutte pure gauche
principal c'était de dire vous allez en
fin de compte gêné les sportives et les
sportifs français puisqu'il bat rapport
à leurs concurrents d'origine dans les
autres pays à lutte contre le dopage ne
se mène pas et je répondais à cela et
puis justement élargissant son combat et
on a réussi d'abord avec les 15 pays à
l'époque de l'union européenne et nous
avons réussi petit à petit et c'est mon
successeur monsieur lavaud à mettre en
place l'agencé mondiale antidopage s'est
il ya eu l'affairé stinat mais moi ce
qui m'a motivé c'est un jour je
réunissais des collégiens
collège avait fait venir le ministre des
sports pour parler tout et puis un petit
garçon qui lève la main et puis qui dit
vacances hors du vestiaire pour aller
jouer au foot
l'entraîneur il nous met un cachet à
effervescents dans la bouche parce que
le dopage ce n'est pas qu'une affaire
des sportifs de haut niveau c'est bien
sûr les sportives et les sportifs de
haut niveau mais ça peut commencer très
tôt et puis le dopage c'est pas
simplement il médicaments c'est par
exemple surentraînement vous savez une
gymnaste et surentraînés à 14 15 ans
elle n'a pas ces règles parce que l
attrape défaut hormonal et ensuite elles
des maladies osseuses ce sont des
sportifs dic sont venus me le dire donc
et toute une série de maltraitance
dans le milieu du sport il fallait agir
il fallait agir fortement alors il ya le
sport il ya la lutte contre le dopage
mais il ya aussi la jeunesse ce sont des
combats que vous avez continué de porter
ici à l'assemblée en tant que député et
puis il ya un autre fil rouge qu'on
retrouve tout au long de ces années vous
en parliez déjà pendant votre campagne
des législatives de 1997 regardez je
crois d'abord que la féminisation dans
la vie politique moderniser cette vie
politique faire je le dis souvent entrer
la vie en politique pour que la
politique change la vie vous êtes une
féministe vous l'avez toujours été on a
l'impression est ce que c'est un
engagement d'ailleurs qui a précédé
votre engagement communiste non parce
que j'ai adhéré au parti communiste
français en 1969 à l'époque il y avait
une magnifique commission des droits des
femmes mais le parti communiste ne se
disaient pas un parti féministe pourquoi
c'est un vol parce que non c'est parce
qu'on estimait que lorsque nous aurons
construit le socialisme en france le
socialisme à les résoudre le problème
des femmes à les résoudre salaire égal à
travail égal à les résoudre toute une
série de choses or ce ce qui freine
l'égalité des droits c'est bien sur
l'exploitation capitaliste et tout mais
c'est la domination patriarcale c'est le
fait que les hommes c'est la cité c'est
le pouvoir c'est le travail les femmes c
est à mantes est épouse être maire c'est
le foyer et on voit bien comment il a
fallu des années des années des lois et
des lois pour qu'on commence à voir la
parité en politique alors en préparant
les missions je vous ai demandé s'il y
avait une image que vous retiendrez de
vos quatre mandats à l'assemblée et vous
m'avez répondu cela regarde
mesdames les ministres ne tardait pas
sur le décret ne tardez pas sur la
circulaire marion l'est marion l'aide
dès l'été je vous remercie
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
bon sortez moi ces excités de
l'assemblée
les ennemis de la démocratie n'ont rien
à faire dans l'hémicycle
alors on veut remettre les choses dans
leur contexte c'était le jour de
l'adoption définitive de la loi sur le
mariage pour tous vous veniez à peine de
terminer votre affaire l'explication de
vote où il était un opposant à la loi a
essayé passé de pardessus
par dessus pour rentrer dans l'hémicycle
donc à une réaction bien sûr du
président claude bartolone et puis des
huissiers mais ça traduisait la violence
qui a eu tout au long de ce débat
parlementaire sera oui parce qu'il faut
se rappeler la violence des
manifestations contre le mariage pour
tous et toutes et si tu vois là c'était
la première fois que je vivais une scène
aussi violentes au sein de l'assemblée
nationale on va passer à un autre
chapitre suivant je vous préviens langue
de bois interdite
alors j'ai fouillé un peu dans nos
archives à l'assemblée est ce qui
ressort c'est aussi votre combativité et
le fait que vous avez toujours était
dans l'opposition
regardez il fallait utiliser tous les
moyens parlementaires y compris la
motion de censure pour exprimer notre
révolte c'est un véritable scandale que
l'intervention du premier ministre qui
vont se prétendent que ce projet de loi
est protecteur pour les jeunes alors
qu'il va leur casser l'ordre on essaye
de passer en force à l'assemblée
nationale c'est inacceptable ben écoutez
c'est quand même incroyable aujourd'hui
en 2016 soit un gouvernement de gauche
qui nous fasse faire ce bond en arrière
par rapport aux accords aux acquis du
code du travail alors les deux les trois
premières interventions c'était contre
des gouvernements de droite la dernière
c'était sous françois hollande est-ce
que c'est pas un peu frustrant de
n'avoir connu l'assemblée que dans les
rangs de l'opposition en quelque sorte
est sûre élection après élection on rêve
qu'il y ait une majorité qui soit une
majorité d'une gauche engagée d'une
brusque est terminée
mais j'ai envie de dire la gauche est
souvent idiote
oui la bouche est idiote on l'a encore
vu ces dernières semaines de se diviser
et incapable de ceux de se rassembler de
se dire on se bat pour quoi on se bat
pas pour nous parti moi je me bats pas
pour le parti communiste française est
un outil parti communiste on se bat pour
qu'un jour il ya un gouvernement de
gauche qui fasse une politique
réellement de gauche pour ça il faut
bien qu'il y ait une majorité époque il
ya une majorité faut bien qu'on se
rassemble ou alors on apparaît comme
quoi on apparaît comme des gens qui sont
contre mais qui à chaque fois on
pourrait gagner comme on l'a fait pour
les autres élections municipales ses
avants ont dit non non non là on va
défendre le score de nos trois partis
parce que quand même qui est important
c'est le score qui va faire notre parti
mais les gens ils en ont rien à faire
des histoires que va faire un parti ou
un autre ce qui vole c'est avoir une
réponse à leurs besoins une réponse à
leurs attentes une réponse à leurs
souffrances donc que je suis très en
colère peut encore une fois on se
retrouve devant ce choix chaque fois où
on nous dit il faut choisir entre le
pire est il moins pire et il n'y a plus
d'espoir et puis d'espérance alors et se
détendent un peu autour d'un verre si ça
vous va
alors il ya à l'assemblée un endroit un
peu secret et réservé aux députés c'est
la buvette de l'assemblée est ce qu'on y
croise beaucoup de femmes oh oui je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ça se mélange
vraiment c'est à lui aussi on règle des
problèmes on discute on se voit la cites
a lui aussi des petites réunions de vous
avez passé beaucoup de temps non je suis
peu imprudent pas non je peux tout va
très bien bon bah quand même si vous
deviez invité un ou une députée pour un
dernier verre à la buvette avant de
quitter l'assemblée ce serait qui a
justement comme les députés peuvent y
aller tout au long de leur mandat
j'éviterai mes collaborateurs qui eux
n'ont pas le droit d'y aller a eu mais
vous pourriez les faire entrer en jeu
les frères entre exceptionnellement jeu
je ferai des yeux doux à un peu de la
buvette pour lui dire mais s'il est
passé une fois l'iss voilà on va
trinquer ensemble parce que vous savez
un député sans ses collaboratrices et
collaborateurs
il n'a pas la capacité d'être à même
d'être au courant de l'ensemble des
dossiers de comprendre les
problématiques de se forger son opinion
c'est aussi moi je discute beaucoup avec
un collaboratrices et collaborateurs on
parle beaucoup parce que des fois on
n'est pas d'accord il c'est de
convaincre voilà et il ya un travail
d'équipé un travail d'équipé mois pour
moi ça a été essentielle tout au long de
ses mandats quel conseil est ce que vous
donneriez à ceux qui vont siéger après
vous dans les cinq ans qui viennent
ça va vous étonner je leur dirai il faut
faire de la politique c'est un gros mot
aujourd'hui sur de la politique a oui
moi j'ai entendu pendant des débats à
l'assemblée des députés de la majorité
dire mais vous faites de la politique ah
bon on fait de la politique à
l'assemblée nationale qu'est ce que
c'est la politique c'est un choix de
société qui se déclinent après à travers
des lois à travers d opposition à
certaines lois d amendements voilà le
débat mais c'est au mans je dirais c'est
s'est redonné le goût
ou discours politique savez je me dis
quand je relis il fait toujours plaisir
à relire les grands discours victor hugo
jean jaurès à l'assemblée nationale il
prenait du temps mais il disait des
choses
nous dès fois en deux minutes en cinq
minutes on dit pas grand chose on va
parler de votre vie d'après après
l'assemblée
alors vous quittez l'assemblée mais on
vous sent pas du tout prête à abandonner
le combat politique la non non c'est sûr
mais vous vous avez rappelé talent tout
à l'heure les inégalités sociales les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes tout bon les injustices les
atteintes à la dignité je veux pas
arrêter de me battre je me suis toujours
battue depuis
1969 à 9,68 j'ai mis en grève au lycée
j'étais en terminale au lycée de filles
rappel en 68 donc non je vais continuer
leur rejet continu et différemment je
vais continuer je veux absolument
recréer une association féministe dans
ma ville parce qu'on en a pu donc je
vais mener ce combat et puis voilà je
vais continuer à être sur les marchés a
distribué du matériel à faire la
politique est une militante militants de
tout cela à nos terrains oui tout
simplement pour terminer l'émission je
vous propose trois films à vous de
choisir celui dont le titre vous
correspond le mieux tout le monde n'a
pas eu la chance d'avoir des parents
communistes joyeuse retraite ou battle
of sexies je sais pas si vous connaissez
ce dernier film mais ça raconte un peu
le combat de billie jean king et est une
grande joueuse de tennis qui s'est battu
pour que les femmes gagnent autant que
les hommes dans les tournois de tennis
non je vais choisir bon c'est pas une
surprise tout le monde n'a pas eu la
chance d'avoir des parents communistes
d'abord parce que la sto geoffrey de
face
c'était très drôle à puis je voir
l'humanité ancienne formule avec une
journaux de l'époque etc et avoir des
parents engagés s'est aussi fait
beaucoup le débat dans les écoles dans
les collèges dans les lycées et à chaque
fois je termine en disant engagé en
politique dans le monde associatif
syndical où vous voulez parce que quand
on est engagé on est libre on ne subit
plus et je pense que si j'ai pu
transmettre cette idée là quand on
s'engage on ne subit plus
on est un homme ou une femme libre c'est
une belle façon de terminer les missions
merci beaucoup mariage effet d'être venu
partager cette dernière séance avec nous
merci
m
[Musique]